[Music]
google coordinate is engine or gk is not
auto grade feature helps to keep your
cluster nodes up to date with the
cluster control plane version whenever
the control plane is updated
node output bridge provides several
benefits
lower management overhead
with this you don't need to manually
update the nodes when the contour plane
is upgraded
better security with this feature gke
ensures that the security updates are
automatically applied
easy of use provide a simple way to keep
your
up to date with the latest kubernetes
features
in this video we will cover how to
configure node out of braids in gke
if you are running a gk cluster the two
most common ways to configure it are
either by using google cloud console or
google cloud cli
first we will learn how to enable node
out operates for an existing node pool
using google cloud console
in the google cloud console go to
kubernetes engine page in the cluster
list select the cluster you want to
configure
click the nodes tab then
click the note pool for which you want
to enable app to upgrade
on the notes pool details page click
edit
under the management section select the
enable out upgrade check box
click save
wait for confirmation notification
there you go you have successfully
enabled node tools to be auto upgraded
now let's learn how to enable node out
upgrades using google cloud cli
we will use cloudshield in this example
before running the google cloud cli
ensure that you have the following
information
notebook name
your cluster name
and the sun where the node pool is
located
run the following command
finally
you can verify that your outputs have
auto upgrade enabled by using gcloud
described commands as follows
congratulations you have successfully
enabled node pools to be out upgraded
one last note
clusters enroll to our release channels
can also be upgraded in this scenario
auto upgrade is enabled by people and
cannot be disabled
finally
if you are running a gke autopilot
cluster
node out upgrades are enabled by default
and cannot be overridden check out the
documentation for more information on gk
now out of grades
[Music]